I feel like I have to just start this
interview off by saying from one tall
Queen to another I like fully appreciate
the fact that there's another six foot
plus woman out there representing so I
do what I can
uh you know it's taken me years to
really like own that space as well it's
not easy Society really really makes
women feel that
it's more usual for them to be smaller
then take up space and it takes time to
to get there but I do what I can one of
the things I and there's so many things
I want to talk about but I know we only
have a little bit of time but to start
you know you're cast in this role you
have Peter Morgan's fantastic scripts
but I'm wondering what outside research
you did apart from the scripts beside
you know as far as Diana's life is
concerned like did you read the Andrew
Morton biography did you kind of you
know what what kind of written research
did you kind of dive into while you were
preparing to take this on uh I
definitely read Andrew's biography I I
read a lot of different books
um I watched a lot of things I watched a
lot of documentaries there's so much
available and I had time to do it as
well which was a huge luxury so I really
kind of swam through a lot of it it's
interesting in terms of written archival
things I also found out quite quickly
that
I would start reading a book and I was
always sort of like really drawn to it
because I I was doing that I was in that
phase of of prep where you just are
gleaning all information and then seeing
kind of what sticks but um
after a little while into each book I
read
I sort of would pull up out of it
almost getting defensive about it and
realizing that there's always an angle
and an agenda that the author has and so
was almost near and easier to read just
kind of basic factual information and
also watch
watch footage when it comes to your
performance I think one of the things
that's really impactful is you grasp a
lot of the little nuances that she had
physically it come through you know
watching this season how much of your
preparation involved studying her
movement her body language and kind of
you know trying to emulate that because
it really does feel like it it's not an
impression like there are scenes where
it feels like you're kind of embodying
her in a way
well I I I
do I mean I've watched an enormous
amount and I I knew you know in in
instinctively that that's a really
important layer that you get right same
as any sort of vocal work and
um we have a movement coach on the crown
her name's Polly Bennett and she it's
it's she's kind of a genius and it's her
job to to sit down with us should we
want to do that work with her and really
kind of work through watch things and
speak about them and understand
why certain things are happening
physically rather than just sort of
going oh the character does this
um
so
yeah it was it was it was a huge layer
of the process and I spent a lot of time
thinking about it one of the things I
think struck me about watching the
season is that you get the distinct
sense of the difference between who
Diana was in public and who she may have
been in private how did you try to
distinguish those two sides from one
another in your approach to playing her
well I think it's it comes down in a way
to Peter's writing of her because that
distinction is very clear in the way
he's written her there's this sort of
public-facing version of this character
and that's a that's a face that's a sort
of layer that has to be put on that's
um a degree of protection but also a
kind of role that people expect of you
and a huge amount of pressure on that
and then obviously if that's something
that's being asked of a person then they
have to they have to decompress and they
have to take that off and and then I
think the thing underneath it which is
something that Peter wrote and something
I really Embrace as an actor is that the
thing underneath that is actually a very
vulnerable thing it's a kind of very raw
thing and it's kind of um
we definitely see it with Emma and then
I see I think we see it through season
five it's something that's still forming
because it's very difficult to to grow
into yourself naturally I think when
you're being observed from so many
angles it's it's
so difficult because in order for that
to happen you need
you need balance and you need privacy
and you need all those things that are
sort of human
you know should be human rights in a way
and um and people who are under the
spotlight like that don't always have
access to those things so one scene that
I really wanted to ask you about is the
one in episode nine Charles visits Diana
in the apartment and the two are kind of
reflecting on their marriage now that
it's officially over you know the
divorce has been finalized it felt like
a very intimate scene almost like a play
in a lot of ways I'm wondering how many
takes was that for you and Dominic to do
like what was that like to film on the
day I'm just curious as to how all that
kind of came together well we actually
shot it over three days and we kind of
wrote We this there's different sets
involved in it so we we kind of move
through the sets and in a way it wasn't
like doing a play it was
um we we got to rehearse it which is you
know luxury when you do TV it was nice
and
um I'm a theater actor really by trade
so that's that's very comfortable for me
to have that kind of time and space to
think about it and then
um
we I mean we did quite a few takes in a
way we had time to do it so we used it
we kind of pushed it in lots of
different directions and we did lots of
different variations of it and played
around with versions of how it not with
the writing but the feeling of how it is
affecting them or How It Ends or so yeah
I mean
um that was a joy to do that because it
wasn't something that
we didn't feel the constraints of time
which is something that affects you a
lot when you're making TV we
we really got to um
delve and delve into it and and it was a
joy to do it with dom because he's um
he's an amazing actor so I I loved we
really both loved doing that scene
because it's almost the only scene we
get together and so it was a real treat
to come in and do that for a few days
just really quick looking ahead you know
the final season is there anything that
you wanted to approach differently in in
how you know you come to Diana I know
you're probably doing quite a bit more
work with Khalid specifically you know
we kind of see the seeds of that
relationship that are sewn in episode
and we're in season five that he was
going to become very important in season
six so I don't know if there's anything
you can kind of tease for you know where
the last season's going or no I don't
want to give anything away and and we're
and we're still making it at the moment
so I'm just gonna keep
that's fair enough
um I am all at a time in the questions
and thank you so much um for taking the
time out of your day to sit and talk
with me it's been such a pleasure to
watch you this season and I'm looking
forward to seeing how this all wraps up
next season as well so thank you for
your time thank you have a nice day